[Music]
hello, how are you, andrés gonzález,
with an informative envelope for today, Thursday
, July 29, we remind you that
the mandatory use of masks in Nevada begins at midnight,
again, the Center for Disease Control and
Prevention recommends face
masks for all  places of
high transmission this includes
clark county nevada leaders imposed that
rule after a high spread of the
[Applause] variant
and today we will follow up on the
bucks nevada days incentive program all
you need to participate is to have been
fully vaccinated or  have received
at least one dose of
the cob vaccine and the winners will be
announced from 6 pm this
weekly draw will last until August 26
and we move on to sports since today is
played in the semifinals of the cup  gold
at four thirty in the afternoon
you will be able to enjoy qatar versus the usa and
followed by that match they face
mexico and canada  s two winners
will come to las vegas to play the
final inside the stadium they choose this
sunday
we are less than two months away from the big
return of life is beautiful the
three-day music festival that starts
from september 17 tickets
are already sold out  but the organization is
still looking for volunteers to
help them you have to be over 18
to fill out the application for more
information visit airbus now dotcom
diagonal in Spanish
and now we move on to the weather forecast
we will have some chances of
minimal rain for the valley
today  reaching a high of
105 degrees however for tomorrow and
saturday there will be a clearer chance
of storms which could bring
another round of flooding lots of sun and
heat for next week have
a nice day i am andrés gonzález and
this was about  news
now news in spanish
[Music]